one of the things that's extraordinary
about executive education offerings is
that the Stanford Graduate School of
Business is of course located in the
heart of Stanford University which in
turn is located in the heart of Silicon
Valley so this is a center of innovation
it's at the cutting edge of technology
this is where many of the brand-name
startups in the world have been founded
and executive education programs give
our participants the opportunity to come
to Stanford or to come and join us if
we're abroad in their location and
understand what some of these
cutting-edge innovative ideas are and
how they can take those ideas and really
propel their organizations forward we're
able to draw on all the schools in the
university and bring together experts
from each of these areas that can help
us understand and focus on the business
problems of today our faculty are an
outstanding set of social scientists who
observe and analyze the business world
and who are able to distill what they
learn from their observations into
actionable managerial plans and
frameworks their cornerstone of our
campus reads dedicated to the things
that haven't happened yet and the people
who will dream them up and I think that
in a nutshell captures the essence of
the GSB
you